here's the timeline of the history of
genetics beginning with the work of
Gregor Mendel we have reached this point
the experiment which proved that its DNA
which is the genetic material clearly
the next step would be to understand the
structure of DNA so how was this
biomolecule structured what are its
constituent molecules let's find that
out in this video the structure of the
DNA molecule was discovered in the early
years of 1950s
note that the structure was discovered
not the molecule the discovery of DNA
molecules predates to the 18th century
but DNA was ignored for a long time and
it was proteins that grabbed a lot of
attention
however post Griffiths transformation
experiment the other two notable works
in the timeline helped shift the focus
towards DNA so around the early years of
1950s an English chemist named rosalind
Franklin started working on DNA
molecules
she isolated the DNA crystals and shown
x-rays on them as a result she obtained
fine images of the structure of the DNA
molecules according to so says the best
one looked somewhat like this around the
same time Francis Crick and James Watson
two scientists in the field of genetics
worked on the structure of DNA and
reached a similar conclusion like
Franklin did however according to
sources they were fortunate to receive
better an earlier recognition compared
to Franklin they even shared a Nobel
price with Morris Wilkins for the
discovery of the double helical
structure of DNA so let's understand how
exactly this double helical structure
looks we may have come across the
structure of DNA somewhere is this how
it really looks
yes according to Franklin Watson and
Crick the DNA is made up of three major
components one is a pentose sugar
molecule called deoxyribose how is this
obtained
it's obtained by removing one oxygen
atom from a ribose molecule does the
name deoxyribonucleic acid
the second component this phosphate
group this helps bind the two
deoxyribose molecules together the third
and the fifth carbon atoms of the
adjacent deoxyribose molecules are bound
by the phosphate groups
lastly the nitrogenous base forms the
core of the double helix these are four
different molecules that bind in pairs
two of them are called purines and the
other two are called pyrimidine
adenine and guanine are the two purines
which bond with the pyrimidine thymine
and cytosine and any purine bind with
any pyrimidine no it's a thumb rule that
adenine always binds with thymine while
guanine binds with cytosine only these
molecules are bound to each other with
the help of hydrogen bonds adenine binds
with thymine with the help of two
hydrogen bonds guanine and cytosine
however bind with three hydrogen bonds
did you know that one unit consisting of
deoxyribose molecule one nitrogenous
base and a phosphate group is called a
nucleotide and what if the phosphate
group is removed from this nucleotide
unit it's called a nucleoside then nora
wants to know if there's any way of
measuring a DNA molecule what about its
dimensions watch the next part to know
more
the dimensions of DNA are very simple
and easy to remember the diameter of the
double helix is around two nanometers
the double helical strand has one major
and one minor groove that makes up one
turn the length of one turn is around
3.4 nanometers and there are around 10
base pairs in one turn now can you help
me with the distance between the two
adjacent base pairs it's simple the
distance is 0.34 nanometers
it's simply 3.4 divided by 10 this is
how the molecules are arranged so in
this double helix this portion is the
backbone which is made up of the
deoxyribose molecules and the phosphate
groups whereas this portion that forms
the core is made up of the nitrogenous
bases now can you guess the chemical
nature of DNA since it contains
nitrogenous bases you would say that DNA
is basic in nature right but that's not
true
DNA is in fact acidic in nature the
presence of phosphate groups makes the
molecule acidic in nature what about its
physical appearance can you tell me how
long can this double helix be let me
tell you an interesting fact if all the
DNA from a single cell is pulled out and
stretched then it would touch
approximately 2 meters in length yes
it's that long but if the DNA stretch is
so long then how does it fit into such a
tiny nucleus we know that a cell is
extremely tiny and the nucleus occupies
a very small portion of the tiny cell so
how does such a long stretch of DNA fit
into such a tiny space the answer is
quite simple how do we fit a long
telephone wire in a small space that's
right using the process
of coiling similarly coiling the DNA
helps reduce its volume and fits it into
the tiny nucleus but what does it boil
air out is there any support for the
structure or does the long stretch coil
around itself well there are highly
specialized proteins that help us in
this these are called the histone
proteins a total of five histone
proteins help in the wrapping of the DNA
molecule histone proteins namely h1 h2 a
h-2b h3 and h4 serve this purpose among
these the h-2a h-2b h3 and h4 come in
doubles to form a ball like structure
which looks somewhat like this the
stretch of DNA then easily wraps around
this octamer formed and what function
does the h1 serve basically the h1
protein helps in attaching the DNA to
the octamer and keeping it intact on
place in other words it helps to hold
the complete structure this unit of the
DNA string wrapped on the histone core
is called nucleosome thus the structure
resembles something it does it looks
like a bead having a string wound around
it that is the reason why the
nucleosomes are referred to as the beads
on a string structures any idea what
kind of a structure is obtained from
this this kind of coiling forms the
basic unit for the formation of the
chromatin structure yes we know that
chromatin and thus the chromosomes are
made up of DNA so it is this pattern of
arrangement of the DNA that forms coils
and helps in the formation of the
chromatin structure
[Music]